2019 last pick in round one after the
new england patriots won super bowl 53
went to receiver nikhil harry at the
time
there was a belief that the patriots had
him rated even higher than number 32 and
now
it's falling apart and the evidence has
been there from the moment the patriots
launched free agency by signing a couple
of tight ends signing a couple of
receivers
nikhil harry
looking like he's on shaky ground
there's been persistent reports and
rumors that the patriots may cut him
that he may just not even be there and
now his agent instead of being fired
wants
his guy to be able to quit via a trade i
don't know that anyone's going to trade
for it
with with the last two years of a
first-round rookie contract and yes it's
number 32 so it's it's lower money than
it would be if it was number two
but that's a seven-figure commitment
each of the next two years that a team
would take on if they trade for his
contract i don't know that anyone's
going to want to do it i think at the
end of the day the patriots may just
have to cut him
regardless the broader point
maybe the patriots should just give up
drafting receivers in the first three
rounds i look back over the past 20
years yeah dion branch in 2002 a third
round pick ended up being a super bowl
mvp the rest of maybe he was a second
round pick either way round two or round
three i i round three is what's sticking
out in my brain
plenty of second round picks third round
picks and nikhil harry the first
first-round pick that the patriots used
on a receiver since terry glenn
before bill belichick was the head coach
harry just hasn't worked out and the
guys on the board when they picked harry
included terry mclaurin d.k metcalf aj
brown debose samuel no guarantee any of
those guys would have worked out because
here's the reality
it's easy to say
the patriots are picking the wrong guys
but it's not like they are reaching for
guys that no one has ever heard of no
one's saying for example when the
patriots take nikhil harry well he's a
fifth round prospect on
you know 28 other boards
they're just like yeah okay nikhil harry
it was time for him to be drafted so if
it wasn't the patriots someone else
would have taken him the question is
how are the patriots developing
something sims and i have talked about
in the past how much of it is the
coaching staff not properly teaching the
coaching staff not trusting the coaching
staff not being patient
that it's sink or swim
at the first sign of sync
they go with someone that they know can
swim because that guy's been in the nfl
for multiple years he's been around the
block he knows the ropes i i think
that's one of the potential problems and
when it comes to drafting there's a
point sims has made
the patriots will often prioritize
intangibles like leadership and love of
the game over raw ability well
sometimes you end up in a mess like this
because you you looked too heavily
at what kind of a guy you were getting
and you didn't look enough at what kind
of a player you were getting regardless
it's not working for the patriots at the
receiver position
and
either they fix it or they just sign
veterans and the way the receiver
position is going with so many great
receivers coming out every year there
will be a glut of free agents every year
and that may be the better way for the
patriots to handle it if they're not
willing or able to develop a young
receiver let someone else develop the
young receiver and then you pay him
especially because the receiver position
is becoming a lot like the running back
position where there are more great ones
than uh the teams out there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports